[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui allié
à gland professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à la sorbonne qui a déjà
publié plusieurs livres sur la seconde
guerre mondiale le nouveau s'intitule la
france à l'envers il sort directement
poche chez folio c'est sur le régime de
vichy et les guerres civiles qui l'a
opposé à la résistance pendant
l'occupation et même après l'occupation
pendant la libération bonjour allié à
gland le
régime de vichy qui s'installe pendant
l'été 40
en quoi est ce la france a lover j'ai
choisi ce titre de la france à l'envers
pour montrer que ce régime a initié une
forme de guerre civile qui commence dès
l'été 40
c'est à dire avant même que ce régime et
quelques jours ou quelques semaines il
entreprend de désigner parmi les
citoyens qui est digne d'être français
qui est digne de le rester et qui n'est
pas digne d'être français
donc il ya plusieurs catégories qui sont
immédiatement désigné la toute première
étant ce qu on appelle la dissidence
c'est à dire ceux qui ont choisi de
suivre le général de gaulle ils sont
très peu nombreux en juillet 40
ensuite il y à ce que charles maurras
avait appelé l'anti france c'est à dire
les juifs les communistes les
francs-maçons toute personnalité étant
susceptible de perdre la nationalité
française puisque dès l'été 40
s'installe une commission qui est
chargée de dénaturaliser c'est à dire
d'enlever la nationalité française à
ceux qui ont pu l'acquérir sous la
troisième république dans les années 20
dans les années 30
alors le régime de vichy se bâtit sur la
défaite
il a quelque chose de de dexia thouars
en fait il faut expier la défaite c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles on va
trier le bon grain de l'ivraie parmi les
citoyens français mais on sent bien que
la défaite ses fondateurs et d'ailleurs
ce qu'ils reprochaient à l'anti france
c'est en tout cas aux gaullistes ou la
dissidence par deux et moi c'est de
vouloir continuer la guerre donc la
défaite c'est très important et la
question évidemment qui s'est toujours
posée qu'il se posait à l'époque et qui
se pose même encore aujourd'hui c'est au
fond la france pouvait-elle continuer la
guerre la france pouvait tenter de
continuer la guerre parce qu'elle avait
un empire absolument intacts il y avait
évidemment un problème de logistique
puisqu'il fallait hachémi
des troupes de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée qu'on dépend des beaucoup
de llanelli de la marine anglaise
mais si vous voulez la décision qui a
été prise d'embarquer sur le mas il ya
un certain nombre de députés et de
membres du gouvernement
elle a été prise à bordeaux en conseil
des ministres ensuite on change d'avis
et ceux qui sont embarqués sur le
massilia se font arrêter à leur arrivée
comme pierre mendès-france
donc si vous voulez avant même que la
défaite soit complètement établie il y a
tellement de tension et de manoeuvre à
l'intérieur du gouvernement et autour du
gouvernement à bordeaux qu'on a pu
effectivement penser des contemporains
le disent que cette défaite avait été
une aubaine politique pour certains et
ça je pense que on peut vraiment être
certain qu'il y a eu en tous les cas un
tel désordre et un tel désaccord une
telle désignant politique qu'il n'a plus
été possible de penser sérieusement
continuer la guerre on aurait pu prendre
l'exemple de tant de gouvernements qui
était parti en exil
que ce soit à londres ou au caire ou
ailleurs beaucoup de gouvernements dont
le pays avait été envahi par l'abbé
remarques étaient partis en exil
donc c'était aussi une possibilité horla
l'exil c'était l'afrique du nord
l'algérie c'était trois départements
français donc pas tout à fait l'exil
on voit bien il ya une grande grande
lucidité chez chez charles de gaulle à
ce pont là quand on va écouter ou quand
on lit plus exactement le texte de ses
discours du 17 18 juin on voit bien qui
comprend hilal de l'avant surtout monde
il comprend ce qui va se passer on
comprend que cette guerre va devenir
mondial que il s'agit seulement d'une
bataille
il comprend que les américains vont
rentrer dans la bataille
il comprend que les russes et les
allemands font finir par s'opposer
il a une lucidité extraordinaire enfin
son voit bien que c'est le défaitisme
qui préside et notamment chez chez
pétain c'est un défaitiste pétain au
fond il était déjà
défaitiste pendant la bataille de verdun
dont on lui prête qu il en a été le
vainqueur ce qui est totalement faux
puisque ils n'étaient déjà plus le le
commandant en chef de l'armée
quand quand la bataille a été remportée
6 mois après son départ mais peu importe
c'est un défaitiste pétain et on voit
bien que de gaulle celle inverse
oui alors le terme de défaitistes a été
forgée non pas par les historiens mais
par les contemporains qui ce terme de
défaitistes désigne ceux qui ont préféré
demander l'armistice au plus tôt sans
avoir en tous les cas à à attendre ou à
redouter quelque chose et c'est
précisément ce terme qui va désigner
tous ceux qui étaient dans le clan de
pétain avec un projet de gouvernement et
un projet de régime
derrière c'est à dire que on a pensé et
ça on le dit à londres dans les
renseignements politique que cette
demande d'armistice était peut-être une
mesure de gouvernement une mesure
intérieur c'est à dire que ça n'avait
plus rien à voir avec la guerre mais une
manière pour une faction de s'emparer du
pouvoir
avec un programme de rénovation
nationale
qui est antirépublicain derrière le
terme de d'effectifs il y à tout ça il
ya tout un programme que l'on pourrait
qualifier de fascistes mais qui n'est
plus tellement désigné comme fasciste
par les travaux des historiens
alors justement la question du ferry la
question du fascisme reste une vraie
question en ce qui concerne le régime de
vichy
est ce que c'est un régime fasciste qui
s'installe à vichy à l'été 40 avec son
chef c'est le maréchal pétain avec avec
c'est ça ça on pourrait dire c mip est
ce que cette est ce que ce régime est le
produit de cette droite révolutionnaire
dont parle m stirn elle dans ses travaux
et où il voit l'origine du fascisme et
qui serait né en france pour vous alliez
à gland ces fascistes ou c'est pas
fasciste vif
c'est pas fasciste premièrement parce
qu'ils n'en n'ont pas les moyens mais il
y a une inspiration fasciste qui éclaire
simplement le l'inspiration de vigie
elle et elle est plurielle
il n'y a pas une seule inspiration mais
si on va du côté de l'inspiration
fasciste indéniablement c'est un régime
autoritaire qui prône le corporatisme
qui mettrait fin à la lutte des classes
c'est un régime anti républicain c'est
un régime xénophobe et raciste et mais
pourtant ils n'ont pas les moyens d'un
projet fasciste car dans la définition
du fascisme
il y a par exemple un programme
d'expansion territoriale
or vichy c'est le contraire c'est la
france du repli c'est la france des
clochers des terroirs de la terre qui ne
ment pas et donc vous voyez bien que
c'est une france du repli qui va trouver
dans la chasse dans la traque de ses
ennemis intérieurs eu un modèle de
rénovation est ce qu'on explique c'est
moins la défaite que les errements de la
république les errements du front
populaire des congés payés de d'une
sorte de fainéants teese qui a pu
prendre les français qui ont revendiqué
et qui n'ont pas voulu servir disait le
maréchal pétain dont kylie a
indéniablement dans l'entreprise du
régime de vichy dit l'état français une
entreprise personnelle autour du
maréchal pétain
mais il faut rappeler que le maréchal
pétain n'est pas plus fasciste qu'un
autre au contraire c'est dans les années
celui qui passe pour être le plus
républicain des grands chefs militaires
qui sont encore en vie et depuis donc la
première guerre mondiale
oui il ne reste guère que le maréchal
pétain marshall pétain est appréciée à
droite comme à gauche dans les années 30
et quand on fait appel à lui c'est un
recours unanime
vous voyez il y a une forme d' unanimité
autour de sa figure
alors certains vont être déçus très vite
et le projet personnel
autoritaire c'est sûr on ne peut pas
l'enfermer dans les cadres du fascisme
il y à bien d'autres imprégnation
notamment dans un programme qui va
emprunter à la technocratie des années
30 aux planisme des années 30 à une
forme de modernisme de réforme de l'état
le tout donc dans un contexte
autoritaire mais je pense que la grande
question qui divise
d'un côté les gaullistes appelé
dissidence et de l'autre côté ceux qui
ont cru pouvoir soutenir la révolution
nationale
la grande différence c'est de prendre en
considération la guerre et l'occupation
c'est à dire que dans un pays des faits
est ce qu'on peut vraiment rénover la
vie quand il n'ya pas de vie politique
pas d'assemblée pas de parlement pas de
vie parlementaire et que tout est soumis
à l'autorisation des allemands il ya
effectivement une autre différence alors
on peut discuter sur les visées
expansionnistes est ce qu'il ya vraiment
forcément de l'expressionnisme dans le
fascisme l'espagne a été fasciste sous
franco est là et le portugal était
fasciste sous salazar il n'avait pas
spécialement de visées expansionnistes
et on pourrait discuter du fascisme au
chili sous pinochet ou au brésil sous
les militaires et il n'y avait pas de
visées expansionnistes mais il ya une
vraie différence aussi avec le régime de
filles entre le régime de vichy et tous
les tous les partis tous les régimes
fascistes ces cas pas de parti unique
il ya les assemble deux parties sont
interdits mais par ailleurs du côté des
collaborationnistes des pro allemand il
ya il ya plein de partis qui vivent et
qui se tirent la bourre d'ailleurs si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi qui critique
d'ailleurs le régime de vichy ya pas de
parti unique mais c'est peut être aussi
parce qu'ils sont au pouvoir
au fond le maréchal pétain n'a pas
besoin d'un parti unique il est au
pouvoir le parti ça sert à conquérir le
pouvoir
là le pouvoir lui tombé dans
l'escarcelle oui vous avez raison il n'a
pas besoin de parti unique et ils
refusent parce qu'en fait ce qu'on
appelle les collaborationnistes sont
ceux qui sont déçus par le régime de
vichy au départ et charles maurras le 17
une divine surprise
mais à l'été 40 quand le maréchal refuse
la fondation d'un parti unique et
préfère une légion des combattants
français qui est
voilà qui rassemble tous les milieux
anciens combattants toutes les
associations d'anciens combattants et
qu'on appelle les yeux et les oreilles
du maréchal il préfère cette
organisation cette légion qui n'est pas
armé 1 le terme peut faire penser que
c'est des militaires pas du tout mais en
tout cas c'est cette association
d'anciens combattants s'appelle la
légion française des combattants
il préfère cette imprégnation parce que
ce sont eux qui vont être les
colporteurs de la révolution nationale
dans les villages dans les régions c'est
eux qui vont amener la propagande et
susciter l'adhésion au maréchal pétain
et à son régime
oui le projet de parti unique il est
plutôt ceux des collaborationnistes qui
du coup vont partir à paris et avec les
allemands avec le soutien financier et
logistique des allemands vont tenir
vichy dans une forme de oui c'est ça de
menace d'un contre gouvernement qui
serait parisien et qui serait
collaborationniste et pour le coup
vraiment fasciste auto-déclaré pro nazi
est clairement fasciste donc dans une
alliance total avec l'allemagne nazie
c'est pour ça aussi que le régime de
révolution nationale des pères français
se démarquent d'une certaine manière de
ces extrêmes puisque ceux qui vont
échouer à établir un parti unique qui
vont le réclamer sans arrêt vont partir
à paris et devenir des
collaborationnistes que les allemands
vont aussi soigneusement divisés parce
que les allemands non plus ne veulent
pas d'un parti unique il serait
nationalistes ce parti fasciste français
y seraient nationaliste donc ça
redonnerait à la france une unité que
les occupants ne veulent pas ni dans
son territoire ni dans son programme
politique ni dans son existence alors le
régime de vichy avec le maréchal pétain
à sa tête il est contre la révolution
française et contre son héritage
il est contrôlé lumière il est contre la
démocratie libérale
il est pour établir une sorte de nations
organique comme un corps qu'il faudrait
assainir en se débarrassant de ce que
charles maurras appelait l'anti france
il ya je disais c'est une société fondée
sur des mythes la race française la
france éternelle la terre qui ne ment
pas le travail la famille
la patrie c'est un mythe aussi puisqu'on
sait bien que la france n'a pas toujours
été ce à quoi elle ressemble donc tout
ça sont des mythes qui sont construits
et puis il ya un personnage qui tranche
pour moi avec l'ensemble c'est pierre
laval qui est le qui a été président du
conseil qui est un ancien socialiste
elle aurait effectivement lui il est on
peut le trouver très antipathique pierre
laval mais il n'a pas du tout dans la
tête de l'emploi
la tête d'un régime fasciste il suffit
de voir pierre laval pour se dire tiens
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
parce que pierre laval ça a été
président du conseil c'est un homme
politique auquel les français sont très
habitués qui n'est pas fondamentalement
différente tous les autres on l'appelle
le maquignon comme s'ils cessaient de
marchander c'est ce qui fait laval entre
pétain et les allemands c'est un
maquignon pour vous bien la vesle et un
égaré de la politique et je pense mieux
comprendre le personnage si on essaie de
voir que il tient au pouvoir il tient à
rester au pouvoir ce qui explique son
entêtement à ne pas avoir que les
compromis qu'ils croient faire sont des
compromissions
mais pierre laval on ne comprend pas son
heure de gloire sous l'occupation sans
savoir les liens qu'il a avec auto à bex
et on a des travaux d'historiens qui
montre bien que ces liens sont
antérieures à la guerre
otto abetz tu l'ambassadeur lui aussi
mène un jeu politique et c'est le duo
auto abete pierre laval qui explique la
la la grâce ou la disgrâce de l'un et de
l'autre
ensemble mais pierre laval est un
authentique politiciens qui voient leurs
deux son heure de gloire arrivée et qui
tient tellement au pouvoir qu'il ne le
laissera jamais et qu'ils essaient
encore de rester dans une sorte de
normalité parlementaire alors que les
alliés ont débarqué en normandie
il essaye encore des combinaisons
politiques
je pense que ce qui caractérise la valve
c'est vraiment le
cette habilité politique qui fait qu'on
l'appelle le maquignon mais une extrême
un extrême aveuglement quand tu as la
situation internationale
donc ce sont des français qui vont
rester entre eux à négocier des postes
des situations pouvoir alors que le
monde entier est en guerre c'est
vraiment là le l'erreur politique de
pierre laval qui était un authentique
républicain en tous les cas il a été de
toutes les combinaisons politiques et
des postes politiques très important de
président du conseil dans les années 30
c'est lui aussi qui avait trouvé cette
espèce de parade contre hitler qui
consistait à faire alliance avec
mussolini 1 jusqu'en 1935 c'est le fond
de stresa qui va craquer avec la guerre
d'ethiopie
mais en tous les cas pierre laval n'est
absolument pas susceptibles d'adhérer ni
au fascisme ni encore moins au nazisme
mais celle aux toilettes il faut le
rappeler vérité l'ambassadeur
d'allemagne en france 1 installé rue de
lille et qui étaient dans les comités
france-allemagne de réconciliation de
rapprochement franco-allemand dans
l'entre-deux-guerres donc c'était
d'autant tic militants européens
d'une certaine manière et qui devait
dans le voilà dans les années 30
essayer de mener une forme de balade de
deux discours franco allemand pour
rompre avec le cycle des guerres franco
allemandes depuis 1870 et c'est autour
de ces réseaux salmagne que la
collaboration va s'épanouir aussi parce
qu'ils se connaissent déjà ces des
réseaux qui sont déjà établis alors la
guerre civile qui oppose le régime de
vichy et et les dissidences donc d'un
côté les gaullistes puis ensuite ils
seront rejoints par les les communistes
à partir de l'invasion de l'urss par les
nazis pendant l'écouté 41 mais le
premier terrain au fond de cette guerre
civile de cette lutte d'influencé
lempire vous fait remarquer d'ailleurs
que
le général de gaulle dans son discours
parle de lempire pétain lui dans le sien
parle de la france et de ses colonies
c'est pas la même c'est pas le même mot
alors lempire on va en voir la carte
derrière moi en 1940 c'est le deuxième
plus grand empire du monde après l'
empire britannique
voilà il ya il ya du terrain si quand
l'un des arguments du général de gaulle
c'est dire que la france pouvait se
retirer
le gouvernement aurait pu se retirer non
pas à londres mais dans l' empire et
continuer la lutte aux côtés de ses
alliés anglais il faut dire qu'on a
vraiment on avait la place quoi il ya là
la population aussi il y a les
ressources humaines il ya les ressources
économiques il y a les ressources
financières il ya les ressources
voilà pour l'effort de guerre est
d'ailleurs cet empire français va être
très sollicité et par la france libre et
par vichy va y avoir tout un tas de
souscription qui vont être levés dans l'
empire
il va y avoir des engagements ou un
militaire d engager militaire la france
libre
l'armée d'afrique est très largement
constitué de recrues on dirait coloniale
donc il y a les immenses ressources de
l' empire et de gaulle qui a une vue
large a compris c'est pas le seul à le
dire à l'époque
en tous les cas c'est sa voix qui a
apporté et qui nous est parvenu que l'
empire français était il a le second
empire la puissance mondiale
après l' empire britannique et donc si
vous voulez il était question de
continuer la guerre dans l' empire mais
d'une certaine manière la guerre a été
continue et dans l'empiré parce que
toutes les lois discriminatoires de
vichy s'applique à l' empire
donc pour ce qui est de diviser un ce
que j'appelle la guerre civile et de
faire le tri entre les citoyens toutes
les lois discriminatoires antisémite
s'applique à l'an pire
voyez par exemple que les juifs
d'algérie sont les seuls à perdre leur
nationalité française en masse tous
ensemble c'est les seuls qui perdent non
pas individuellement leur nationalité
mais en groupe parce que ça c'était
possible avec un décret-loi de vichy
vous savez les lois de vichy cd des
ministres qui font rédiger ou qui rédige
qui signe le maréchal pétain signe
pierre laval signe il n'ya pas
d'assemblée nationale qui va examiner la
loi il n'y a plus de parlement donc
voyez ce que valent ces lots
à en termes démocratique pas grand chose
par contre et se sont appliqués au fin
fond de l'indochine française
il a fallu trouver un industriel juif
qui n'avait plus le droit d'exercer son
métier mais on est allé le chercher au
fin fond de l'indochine et donc ne me
dites pas que les nazis étaient en
indochine et dans le cas de l'algérie
les lois anti juives ont continué de
s'appliquer alors même que les
américains avaient débarqué en algérie
ça va continuer encore deux de
s'appliquer pendant quelques mois ah oui
pendant de trop longs mois et le général
de gaulle a été intransigeant là-dessus
et c'est ça faisait partie d'ailleurs de
sa querelle avec le général giraud c'est
que pour lui le débarquement en afrique
du nord n'avait libéré personne puisque
après c'est après ça a été
darlan qui a été reconnu comme
l'autorité par les américains puis le
général giraud et nice ou darlan nice au
giro il n'a été touché à tout l'arsenal
répressif xénophobes et antisémites de
l'état français et de gaulle a insisté
pour que ces lois soient invalidés mais
ça a pris effectivement au moins six
mois après l'opération torch
on voit bien également que aussi bien du
côté de pétanque du côté de de gaulle au
fond on est obligé
de plaire à ses alliés l'allié objectif
de pétain à partir de l'entrevue de
montoire de la politique de
collaboration dont on connaît la célèbre
photo mairie salle pétain serrant la
main de du chancelier hitler il la
france le régime de vichy veut plaire à
l'allemagne c'est à dire de sortir de sa
condition de vaincus pour se ranger
temps si tenté que c'est possible du
côté du vainqueur
aidé en obtenir des avantages est au
fond le général de gaulle est à peu près
dans le même numéro d'équilibriste
sauf que de gaulle et à bien meilleure
politique que pétain avec ses alliés
mais de gaulle doit sortir de la
position de la france qui a été vaincu
pour la faire en juin rentré dans le
camp des vainqueurs auprès de churchill
d'abord et des anglais mais ensuite
auprès des américains de roosevelt qui
vont lui préférer darlan ou ou giraud
plus malléable et même de staline parce
que de gaulle aussi va avoir une
partition à jouer de ce côté là au fond
des deux côtés de la guerre civile
on se charge des alliés puissants oui
alors à la différence près que de gaulle
est extrêmement intransigeant par
rapport à ses alliés dont il ya une
vraie crise comme avec churchill le pain
ça c'est bien connu
et alors que de l'autre côté il ya une
soumission
c'est à dire que maréchal pétain tente
de plaire ou plutôt d'amadouer c'est les
allemands qui ne sont jamais les alliés
et d'ailleurs qui ne considère
absolument pas comme alliés la france de
vichy
du côté des allemands la collaboration
d'état c'est pas compliqué c'est la
france travaille pour l'effort de guerre
allemand donc financièrement
économiquement donc main d'oeuvre forcée
ressources prélevées au maximum et l'a
peut-être la paix le futur traité de
paix sera peut-être équitable voilà mais
on laisse planer le doute
de l'autre côté de gaulle est très
dépendant des alliés britanniques et
américains mais il ne va jamais rien
lâché comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que de gaulle
est intransigeant sur tout ce qui
concerne la souveraineté française
il a défendu à cor et à cri pied à pied
pendant toute l'occupation au point
d'avoir irrité et roosevelt et churchill
plusieurs fois qu'ils ont menacé de lui
couper les vivres
tout simplement donc autant la france
libre est dépendante des capitaux en
anglais surtout depuis de l'effort de
guerre anglo américain autant pétain est
prisonnier est complètement ligoté par
des contradictions car pour lui la
collaboration était effectivement
quelque chose dans l'honneur sur un pied
d'égalité qu'on allait effacer la
condition de vaincus du côté du
troisième reich il n'a jamais été
question de traiter la france autrement
que comme un pays vaincu et qu'il
fallait dépecer et amoindrir pour
toujours ça devait être une sorte de
terres agricoles de colonisation de
germanisation pour certaines parties et
en tous les cas d'exploitation maximale
je vous arrête à l'eag là on fait une
pause on se retrouve juste après et on
continue de parler et du régime de vichy
et de ceux qui s'y opposait à l'époque
dans cette guerre civile qui a
ensanglanté la france pendant toute
l'occupation
[Musique]
nous reprenons cette émission avec est
liée à gland qui vient de publier
directement en poche chez folio la
france allant vers la guerre de vichy
1940 1945 cette guerre c'est une guerre
civile qui oppose le régime de fichiers
à la résistance et qui va continuer même
après la libération puisqu'ils y aura
l'épuration dans les caractéristiques de
vichy il ya vraiment il me semble c'est
ce que j'ai ressenti en lisant votre
livre une lutte contre l'individu contre
l'individualisme alors aussi bien contre
le capitalisme libéral
vichy institue une sorte de capitalisme
diriger un corporatisme également qui va
de qui est censé mettre fin à la lutte
des classes mais enfin c'est toujours
l'initiative individuelle l'individu qui
est dans le collimateur y compris le
matérialisme qu aurait pu défendre les
marxistes par exemple vichy c'est
vraiment autre chose
et oui parce qu'en fait la révolution
nationale met à l'honneur la communauté
française donc d'une certaine manière
si vous n'appartenez pas à cette
communauté
vous êtes exclu et donc parmi les exclus
il y à tous ceux qui sont désignés comme
des ennemis intérieurs d'anti-france
juifs le communisme le franc maçon
donc c'est figure de l'ennemi
définissent à défaut la communauté voyez
est donc dans cette aspiration à la
communauté bien sûr il n'ya plus
d'individus parce que c'est un régime
anti républicain et qui justement renie
complètement l'héritage de la révolution
française qui a institué l'individu le
citoyen le le citoyen soldat où le
citoyen tout court en tous les cas la
citoyenneté telle qu'elle a été définie
les principes de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité sont complètement mis à
l'envers dans un triptyque travail
famille patrie
mais vous savez ce sont des communautés
la communauté du travail la communauté
de la famille et la communauté
dite patriotique alors que du côté de la
france libre on a tout autant vocation à
être patriote mais sauf que le
patriotisme inclus de faire la guerre
aux côtés des alliés est donc dans toute
la résistance évidemment cette valeurs
de patriotisme est complètement refusé à
vichy et est plutôt du côté des
combattants aux clandestins
mais enfin le problème du patriotisme va
se poser aussi vis-à-vis des communistes
qui sont bien plus inféodée à moscou à
l'urss qu'à la france à ce moment là
comment le mariage entre les gaullistes
et les communistes ne va pas du tout
soit il va mettre un certain temps
d'ailleurs et on se demande d'ailleurs
s'il était très sincère il y avait des
volontés insurrectionnelle du côté des
communistes pour la libération qui
parfois d'ailleurs ont tenté d'avoir
lieu dans certaines villes
enfin sans succès voilà tout ça n'allait
pas de soi et ça a pris du temps
c'est un prix du temps ça n'allait pas
de soi mais individuellement certains
communistes n'ont pas attendu
l'opération barbarossa pour rejoindre
les rangs de la résistance
ensuite il y a eu dans la résistance des
organisations communistes comme les
francs tireurs et partisans mais qui
n'étaient pas homogènes en termes de
recrutement beaucoup de résistants ont
participé au front national ou au ftp
aux francs tireurs et partisans sans
avoir jamais eu leur carte au parti
communiste
donc c'est très compliqué mais pour dire
la position du parti communiste à
travers par exemple des organes comme
l'humanité clandestine
c'était que la guerre était une guerre
patriotique que l'on faisait aussi pour
soulager l'armée rouge sur le front
russe et qu'on devait être extrêmement
offensifs notamment par cette pratique
des attentats individuelles contre les
soldats allemands pour que le comment
dirais-je que la france ne soit pas le
repos du guerrier et qu'on fasse la
guerre sur le territoire français comme
se bat
l'armée rouge et les partisans
soviétique le mariage n'a pas été très
facile mais il a été je crois
complètement au s'insère dans la mesure
où la france libre a une vocation à
rassembler tous ceux qui avaient désigné
l'ennemi numéro 1 en la personne en
idéologie nazie
donc ça a été complètement sincère et
d'autre part vous savez dans la
résistance reste anciens tels creuset
qui a eu énormément de rencontres qui
n'était pas possible avant guerre des
chrétiens qui prennent en compte le
combat marxiste des communistes qui
découvrent des royalistes
donc vous savez la résistance elle a
peut-être eu une organisation politique
sur le papier mais à la base ça a été
bien plus mêlés et ça a été des vraies
découvertes
individuel aussi c'est ce que raconte
daniel cordier ou ghislain de bénouville
des rapprochements assez inédit parce
que finalement la chauffe
le point commun ce sur quoi on s'entend
pour mener le combat
c'est vraiment lentilles nazisme
l'antifascisme ça ça a été quand même
très rassembleur sur le terrain ensuite
les pratiques ont pu diverger mais le
fait que par exemple quelqu'un comme
guingouin qui était le chef des maquis
du limousin qui était un instituteur
communiste mais lui il a jamais oubliée
a aucune directive du parti communiste
il n'oublie s'est d'ailleurs pas plus
aux directives qui lui arrivait de la
france libre 1 et c'est comme ça qu'il a
tenus le limousin pendant toute la
guerre avec voilà une autorité qui n'a
pas été démentie fin qui a été critiquée
après guerre mais voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'en réalité cette guerre va
remettre va reposer la question de la
définition de tous les termes
ce qui est par exemple communiste en
trente neuf c'est puis la même chose 1
41 essais puis la même chose en 44 le
parti communiste français à des
évolutions qui sont bien connus
mais qu'ils ne sont pas seulement des
ordres de moscou
en partie oui à la base non c'est autre
chose alors l'acte et l'action de la
résistance pendant toute l'occupation
elle est diverse
il ya une partie qui est lié au
renseignement qui est très importante
parce que ça permet à aux anglais
d'abord puis au aux alliés anglo saxons
de savoir ce qui se passe en france de
ce que font les allemands il ya une
partie aussi qui consiste à faire évader
les aviateurs qui sont tombés en france
et à pouvoir le par certaines filières
lait les faire retourner en grande
bretagne par l'espagne notamment et le
portugal
et puis il ya les les attentats dont
vous parliez danton on dit que c'est
plutôt les communistes qui en était à
l'origine
et est aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit en tout
cas c'est ce que nous disent ça tombe
d'historiens comme olivier wieviorka ou
ou jean lopez qu'au fond la résistance
française a tué beaucoup plus infiniment
plus de français que d'allemands pendant
l'occupation
donc c'était plus une force sur le plan
militaire qui était qui avait un rôle à
jouer dans la guerre civile plutôt que
dans la guerre tout court
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça a
l'air et blanc alors moi je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec cette vision
parce que il y a dans le discours
résistants une sorte d' agressivité
contre contre les allemands en réalité
les attend pas si on regarde les
chiffres vise plus souvent des
collaborateurs que des allemands et
d'autre part le parti communiste et ses
organisations l'organisons spécial a du
mal à recruter des gens qui ferait des
attentats si on compare avec les autres
résistances on voit la même chose à
savoir que prime
finalement la haine de l'ennemi intime
c'est à dire le collaborateur et dans
certaines régions on va avoir des
triangulations terrible où des miliciens
vont
donner des renseignements pour les
allemands les trouve donc si vous voulez
c'est c'est ce qui se passe par exemple
dans la guerre démaquiller une
triangulation qui est mortifère dans
tous les cas de figure donc je sais pas
si on peut conclure avec les historiens
que vous citez sûr voilà ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure je trouve que
c'est beaucoup plus il faudrait nuancer
parce que les les
les configurations locales sont très
différentes d'une région à l'autre mais
ils ont les a tendance à dire qu'au fond
quand on compte le nombre d'allemands
tué par la résistance française pendant
l'occupation
c'est très très peu c'est une centaine
d'allemands et donc y tue beaucoup plus
de français c'est peut-être plus facile
aussi
mais c'est peut-être plus à la portée
des résistants et notamment des
résistants communistes les allemands au
fond c'était plus dur à tuer mais parce
que les chiffres qu'on a ne sont pas
tout à fait définitif encore il est
difficile c'est vrai de tuer des
allemands mais comme les allemands se
venge sur des villages français qui sont
entièrement massacrés voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est une sorte de
comptabilité qu'il n'est pas très clair
et qu'il n'est pas prêt heuristique
c'est dire qu'il ne donne pas une
interprétation possible
par contre qu'est ce que l'on peut dire
c'est que c'est dans cette triangulation
que se situe cette configuration de
guerre civile que moi j'ai voulu étudier
parce que c'est vraiment un angle mort
c'est un angle mort dans
l'historiographie c'est un angle mort
dans la mémoire et qu'on n'a pas envie
aujourd'hui de se rappeler des exactions
notamment de désalement à l'échelle d'un
département
moi j'ai pas mal étudié le département
de la dordogne parce que j'ai eu des
sources dessus un rapport qui a été fait
pour le préfet de la dordogne en 46 1946
47 et kim était quand même en en valeur
la manière dont
dans chaque commune les allemands
avaient procédé à des exécutions sur
dénonciation en fait on peut pas
comptabiliser le nombre d'allemands tués
par des français si on met pas en
balance la manière dont on fait tuer les
uns par les autres et la configuration
de guerre civile c'est ça c'est qui est
responsable de la mort de réfugiés
espagnols par exemple dans tel village
de dordogne
est ce que c'est les miliciens qui ont
donné les noms et les adresses où est ce
que ce son est ce que ce sont les
autorités du sd qui ont décidé
l'exécution ou est ce que ce sont ceux
qui ont tenu les fusils ou est ce que je
veux dire c'est que si on fait une
comptabilité en nombre d'allemands tuée
d'un côté en nombre de français de
l'autre en fait on on ne donne pas à
comprendre un phénomène qui est qui
commanditent le crime qui y participent
qui est l'autorité qui en est
responsable c'est ça la complicité et
ses salles la configuration de guerre
civile et c'est ça la difficulté et
c'est ça qu'il ne s'oublie pas dans les
mémoires
voilà locale ça ne s'oublie jamais de
même on ne comprend pas toujours qu'il
ya un régime à vichy et des
collaborateurs à paris
on se souvient que jusqu'à la vase ion
de l'afrique du nord parler des
anglo-américains il ya une zone libre en
france et on a l'impression que le
maréchal pétain n'a d'autorité du mot le
régime de vichy n'a d'autorité que sur
la france libre may à paris aussi l
administration
il ya une police française à paris cette
police française elle obéit au maréchal
pétain du mois au régime de vichy
il ya également un autre bras armé du
régime de vichy
vous l'avez parlez vous en avez parlé
c'est d'abord le sol là
la légion française des combattants qui
va devenir l'ami liste et puis ensuite
sur à même la légion la lvf qui va
devenir la division charlemagne alors la
lvf ce sont les volontaires français qui
se bat sous l'uniforme allemand sur le
front de l'est et la division ou
charlemagne sont même les waffen ss
français qui se bat alors jusqu'au
dernier moment autour de la chancellerie
à berlin contre les russes alors d'abord
pour comprendre pétain at-il de
l'autorité sur paris en théorie oui il a
le gouvernement qui s'installe à vichy a
autorité sur toute la france y compris
dans la zone occupée et sur le lan pire
sur les dépendances coloniale mais ça
c'est la théorie est donc en fait pour
comprendre le phénomène de collaboration
qui ne s'est pas facile parce que là
aussi il faut se mettre un peu la tête à
l'envers justement il faut comprendre
que vichy collaborent pour affermir sa
souveraineté c'est pas si facile à
comprendre comme ça parce qu'on se dit
mais c'est ça va pas bien si c'est
exactement une souveraineté qui est
faible et donc on doit par exemple
procéder aux arrestations
c'est le gouvernement français qu'il va
procéder
la police française qui procède aux
arrestations non pas parce qu'ils sont
spécialement nazis c'est parce que ils
gardent ainsi leurs autorités et donc
bien avant les accords entre bousquet et
hohberg et deux séries d'accords la
collaboration entre polices allemande et
française a déjà lieu et cette
collaboration
elle va ouvrir la zone sud aux allemands
voyez ce que je veux dire en fait la
distinction entre zone sud est zone nord
il ya beaucoup d'autres zones mais elle
et elle est tellement factice que quand
les allemands veulent arrêter d anti
nazi qui sont internés dans les camps en
zone libre
mais ils vont les arrêter et ça bien
avant devant quarante deux voiliers d'un
côté la collaboration
pour la france l'état français
c'est vraiment préserver sa souveraineté
or ils sont sous la coupe des allemands
qui se servent qui pillent et qui
donnent leur avis même sur la
composition de tous les gouvernements
pendant toute l'occupation et qui
partent avec le gouvernement français à
sygma indian wells et d'un côté à une
collaboration du côté allemand c'est une
collaboration pour la guerre pour faire
la guerre donc tout ce qui sert à
l'effort de guerre allemand
on le prend et de l'autre côté à vichy
c'est une collaboration pour un jour
avoir peut-être une place dans l'europe
nouvelle qui sera donc pas s'y fier mais
sous la botte du troisième reich
oui à débusquer
c'était la police française car
looberghe c'était le chef de toutes les
polices allemandes pendant l'occupation
ils ont effectivement travailler
ensemble il ya la police c'est une chose
mais il ya évidemment il ya là alors il
ya une armée d'opérette à vichy ils sont
habillés comme était habillé les soldats
français d'ailleurs tous qui gardent les
ministères c'est pas très puissant mais
il ya la milice avec ses avec son béret
son uniforme la milice est ce que c'est
une puissance les milices est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle a elle recrute facilement
elle est là elle a du poids on a
l'impression que ce sont des nervis dans
les voit d'ailleurs derrière moi alors
qu'est ce que c'est la milice exactement
c'est darnand qui était sa tête qui a
été un héros de la première guerre
mondiale d'ailleurs mai mais est ce que
tu te forces c'est pas vraiment une
force mais c'est une je dirais une
nuisance la milice en fait elle est
issue du service d'ordre légionnaire qui
était donc le service d'ordre de cette
fameuse légion française des combattants
au départ la milice elle n'est même pas
armées
mais c'est parce que ils veulent être
armé pour se défendre contre justement
les attentats de la résistance qu'ils
vont être poussés à se retrouver sous
uniforme allemand
ce que comme laval ne veut pas armer la
milice étant non plus au départ les
allemands non plus mais il arrive darbar
n'en arrive à faire une sorte d'accord a
passé un accord avec les allemands qui
arment la milice ou une partie de la
milice à la france garde seulement de la
milice contre justement un engagement
des miliciens sur le front de l'est
du côté donc de te laver remarques et
d'envoyer l'engrenage il est à ce moment
là saisissant pour que cette milice
soient armés pour se défendre dans le
cadre d'une guerre franco-française
eh bien ça va aller jeter d'une certaine
manière dans cette croisade contre le
bolchévisme qui a évidemment un aspect
tout à fait logique et qui est tout à
fait cohérent avec l'engagement des
miliciens mais c'est c'est pas une force
dans le sens où en tout c'est même pas
trente mille personnes mais pas trente
mille personnes armées dans ses trente
mille personnes ya des sympathisants des
adhérents des groupuscule d'activistes
sont très peu nombreux c'est une poignée
ces quelques milliers
ils sont très redoutable dans la mesure
où ils connaissent le terrain
connaissent le pays il grèce et
localités donc c'est à l'échelle des
localités que la milice fait beaucoup de
dégâts il ya évidemment une bataille de
mots de vocabulaire comme toutes les
guerres de propagande 1 celle qui oppose
la résistance et régime de vichy une
guerre de vocabulaire quand les uns
parlent de libération les autres parle
d'invasion et évidemment puisque
l'afrique du nord va être libéré par les
anglo américains mais pour d'autres
pétain notamment va parler d'invasion il
fera exactement la même chose
à partir du litre de lait du
débarquement du 6 juin 44 et vous vous
montrez dans le livre à quel point pour
de gaulle il est important par exemple
d'apparaître en 30 à pied aussi bien à
bayeux cac à paris on va voir les photos
qui paraissent dans la presse à l'époque
c'est le général de gaulle arrive à pied
il n'arrive pas dans une jeep surtout
pas une jeep américaine n'arrive pas sur
un tank
ils arrivent à pied parce qu'il est chez
lui
c'est la france c'est très important ça
et aussi bien à paris comme on le voit
derrière moi qu à bayeux c'est très
important qu'ils n'apparaissent pas
effectivement comme l'instrument des
alliés parce que toute la propagande de
vichy contre le général de gaulle a
consisté à dire qu'il était voilà entre
les mains des lobbys anglo saxons entre
les mains des lobbies juifs
enfin qu'il est que c'était une
marionnette donc ça il
il était évidemment très important de 2
voilà deux que personnifier la
libération de la france ça se fasse dans
un bain de foule parce que arrivé à pied
ça veut dire aussi pouvoir serrer les
mains et être accueillis à bayeux comme
un trio plater mais de gaulle il doit à
la fois se défier de cette propagande de
vichy mais il doit aussi se défier de
tout acte qui le laisserait voilà
prisonniers des anglo-américains et
bailly c'est très important parce que il
y a tout un remplacement de tous les
cadres de l'administration de vichy qui
se fait en même temps que l'arrivée de
de gaulle 1 parce que il est précédé par
les représentants de la république
les délégués et militaire de la france
qui vont se voilent à prendre la relève
des pouvoirs défaire les préfets qui
était trop vichyssois et établira semble
en tous les cas de d'administration
alternative et keith rennie américaine
ni britannique il ya demain autres
effets de miroir à la fin le régime de
vichy et toutes là toute la clique
collaborationniste au fond se retrouve à
sig marine gun en allemagne dans louis
ferdinand céline l'a raconté dans un
livre célèbre d'un château l'autre ils
sont dans ce vieux château d eau d owen
nolan et évidemment il ya un effet
miroir avec de gaulle au début à londres
tout seul
et même maurice torres tout seul à
moscou puisqu'au souvient que torres a
déserté en 39 et rejoint l'union
soviétique et on l'a gardé la vivent en
attendant en attendant qu'il puisse
revenir en france comme l'aller les
collaborateurs alors pour certains
imaginent qu'ils vont peut-être venir en
france si l'allemagne finit par gagner
la guerre mais déjà plus personne n'y
croit beaucoup à ce moment là bas sauf
ce we are we camp jusqu'au terme du
moment alors c'est vrai que sigg
marignane ça paraît être
voilà une sorte de désastre d'opérette
pincer c'est assez sinistre et en plus
ils n'arrêtent pas de se disputer entre
il ya pas mal de de travaux là dessus et
puis autour il y a quelqu'un qui attend
son heure c'est doriot finalement doriot
était le seul qui était un peu
considérée comme sérieusement fasciste
par les allemands alors que l'ancien
colonisateur yom ancien communiste
fondateur du ppf qui sera devant lier de
gaulle lui refusera sa grâce parce que
paraît-il il là il a vu sur une photo un
uniforme allemand alors doriot n'est pas
fusiller la question il meurt oui je
confesse babiak essais brasil à la photo
oui bien sûr il meurt sa voiture est
mitraillée je crois c'est ça et donc
doriot est le seul qui est alors à côté
tig marine gun pas vraiment un single
mais qui croit réellement que ont fait
de la résistance
c'est à dire comme de gaulle a fait on
n'en voit pas mal de discours sur des
postes de propagande on va même envoyé
des corps francs faire des coups de main
de l'autre côté de la frontière on
imagine pouvoir envoyer les saboteurs
recruter des parachutistes et c'est pour
faire comme de gaulle alors aujourd'hui
ça nous fait sourire mais je pense que
certains y croyait une poignée en tous
les cas on pu croire au tour de doriot
pouvoir un jour reprendre le pouvoir
vous savez la fois dans le iiième reich
l'inextinguible jusqu'aux dernières
heures du raje beaucoup de fanatiques
pense que le troisième reich va pouvoir
grâce à des armes secrètes gagner la
guerre notamment les v1 et v2 et toutes
sortes de fantasmes de d'armes peut-être
des têtes nucléaires qui renverserait
donc le sort des armes
enfin il ya en france l'épuration
alors on est généralement d'accord pour
dire qu'elle a plus volontiers frapper
les femmes d'abord qu'il y avait eu la
mauvaise idée de coucher avec des
allemands mais ensuite les intellectuels
plutôt que les les patrons les
magistrats ou la police vous êtes
d'accord
dans la synthèse que j'ai fait après les
travaux des autres îles et il est très
évident que les intellectuels sont les
premiers qui passent en jugement
d'abord parce qu'on a des traces de
leurs opinions ils ont écrit donc
immédiatement disponible pour un
processus judiciaire
ensuite je trouve qu'il faut nuancer
l'idée que la l'épuration a peu touché
les patrons parce qu'il ya des cas de
figure extrêmement différent et là aussi
ce sont des cas individuels
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que de toute
façon cette épuration n'a fait que
sanctionner le zèle et c'est ce qui
apparaît vraiment des travaux les plus
récents
c'est à dire que si bien sûr on a pu se
jeter sur des femmes ou sur des
personnalités taxé de mots sexuel qu'on
a accusé d'avoir couché avec l'ennemi ce
qui est certain c'est que cette justice
n'a pu prendre en compte que les cas
extrêmement et les deux d'intelligence
avec l'ennemi
puisque c'est de ça qu'il s'agit de
juger et que petit à petit les sanctions
ont été révisées à la baisse ont été
beaucoup atténué mais qu'on a quand même
beaucoup exécuté dans la france de poste
merci à elle et à gland je rappelle que
votre livre s'intitule la france à
l'envers
il paraît directement en poche chez
folio
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
merci à vous
[Musique]